devil facial tumour disease is one of
the most unique and unusual diseases in
the world because it's a transmissible
dancer and to our knowledge there's only
two cases in in biology of these
transmissible cancers one is in the dogs
and the other one is in the devil's
canine transmissible venereal tumor as
its name suggests is a sexually
transmitted cancer and at least the
appearance of tumors on the external
genitalia of both male and female dogs
both the canine transmissible venereal
tumor and that has minion devil facial
tumour disease are transmissible cancers
spread by the transfer of living cancer
cells the canine tumor is very treatable
it's actually very responsive to certain
types of chemotherapy treatment and
actually almost all cases can be cured
within a few weeks through this course
of chemotherapy we're very interested in
understanding why it is that
chemotherapy is so successful with
treating the canine cancer whereas it's
been tried with the Tasmanian Devil
cancer and it's not very successful at
all